one time I love John Gruden you remember
the coach Johnny yeah uh you were on an
email chain with him weren't you I was
on an email town with him that I should
not have been
yeah yeah but anyway so I was like all
right this is what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna this is when he was not coaching
he was just doing his football show all
right I was like I'm gonna do a segment
and in hindsight and saying out loud it
sounds dumb and it was yeah I'm like I'm
just gonna find him I'm finding junker
like just find him and there was no like
there was no like find them and then I'm
gonna it was like I'm just gonna find
him and uh so anyways I was like doing
all this research talking people who
knew
and so replying to Bucks fans DMS yeah
so I was like
I was like I'm gonna find this guy
anyways I ended up in Tampa and they're
like he he is headquarters is in the
Hooters the original Hooters oh wow
like that's where he runs his show from
that's where he shoots his show
and so I was like all right so I went to
the original Hooters I was at the
restaurant and it's in Tampa and I was
eating I was like you guys seen John
Gruden recently and they're like yeah
every day foreign
I was like well where's his office it's
in here right they're like oh no no it's
in corporate I'm like and that's
corporate right across the street across
the parking lot wow you're there huh and
did you wear something nice you just
wore just regular clothes yes wore
regular clothes wow early in my career
yeah yeah I wasn't even at the close
stage of your career
and uh I walked across the street and I
went into the corporate office and I was
like I'm here to see John Gruden
by the way corporate office of Hooters
okay
and uh damn bro that's the corporate
office two of the world when you think
about it it's a corporate office of
every 11 and 12 and 13 and 14 and 15
year old boys I mean that's to get my
hat on
yesterday I didn't even know we were
telling the story today
um but anyway so I gave them tits boy
I also hosted the Hooters conference
this year or the the pageants we can
talk about that later but so I go in
there and I was like I want to see Jon
Gruden they just took me back like take
to his office yeah he wasn't there but
his assistant gave me a tour and he's
like what are you looking for him for
it's like oh
I don't even know what I said oh
I was here to see him you know
yeah yeah so show me around the office
this is where they shoot this this is
where he does this
and they're like this is uh John Daley's
room
and I was like
what do you mean John Daley's room and
they're like and they open it up it's a
you know like The Chronicles of Narnia
a wall that has a bunch of books and you
can push it open yeah it was literally
that you push it open and it was just a
very small room smaller than this room
and it had a mattress on the floor and
like a little putting thing and I guess
John Daly lives in there wow really
inside inside John Gruden's office
inside the Hooters headquarters
and he and they say he Parks his bus out
back and then whenever he just needs a
place to be outside his bus he goes in
there oh wow so he goes and stays in a
bus also yeah that's almost the most
homeless [ __ ] you can do I feel like
like living in Hooters and live in a
like being a bus but I guess if you love
living in a bus these guys are
professional golfers are not even that
good of athletes uh-uh they don't seem
to be yeah there's a lot of fats yeah a
lot of fats I've seen a couple of them
on Broadway oh dude I saw John Daly one
night overdose on I don't even know what
it was Gin I think and get carried out
of a ball like get carried out of a
restaurant yeah not even a bar
what restaurant was it uh it was 12 30
club downtown yeah
now look it's a great establishment it's
the kind of place where you could have
so much fun that you gotta have it you
know they got to send an ambulance for
you because you know your whole vibe is
on fire but yeah they had it had some
dudes carrying them out
and one dude like fire like firemen
carried him you know I keep on waiting
for this to like have like a joke in it
but so far it seems it seems pretty
accurate to what happened yeah and I I
just turned it on one of those people
it's just kind of like video on them I
didn't put it up because it felt kind of
embarrassing but yeah and but the crazy
thing was I saw it happen again Where
They Carried John Daly out of a ball out
of a place I mean it probably happens to
him pretty often yeah I think he's
definitely become kind of like the cat
like he's like the bad you know he's the
bag of clubs dude can you imagine how to
carry him oh I can't even imagine either
catty him out I mean if you're trying to
carry him back yeah you know you want to
walk up those stairs onto the bus so
sometimes it's probably just easier if
it's a smaller person he's at the
restaurant with small people he was
eating Chinese or something yeah let's
take him right into the lame on the
ground damn I can't believe that dude
see that's a good top secret way to go
about business a lot of businesses I
feel like think too much like let's put
the business in this big business you
know Applebee's yeah they're like oh
every time you go and you know whoever
you know everybody's doing Applebee's
bro but it'd be crazy as [ __ ] if you
look under like a a table or you move a
booth and there's like a Marathon gas
back in there so yeah there's just a big
computer John Gruden Gmail
damn dude I wonder if that's where he
was sending those wild emails from
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one